this morning we've got a Twist on the
tiny home phenomena a story about tiny
homes plus a whole lot of hope that
comes along with it we went to Oklahoma
City where one non-profit is using small
houses to change the lives of young
adults who age out of foster care Omar
via Franca has more
here you go ma'am for the first time in
her life twenty-year-old deshiana Berry
has a steady job and for the last two
months
a steady place to call home two things
that were Unthinkable just a few years
ago after spending most of her life in
Oklahoma's foster care system it's very
important to me because growing up I
never had anything to myself you know I
was taken away from my parents when I
was like three months while Barry takes
orders she's getting her life in order
with the help of pivot the Oklahoma City
non-profit provides young people with a
little house to live in as they start
their journey into adulthood I'm very
appreciative of what I have right now
what I was providing with because I
didn't have anything when I first got
here I didn't have any clothes I didn't
have any food I didn't have you know
anything really
many of the residents were homeless like
Barry or aged out of the foster care
system at 18. the little house project
started four years ago with three cozy
Cottages but as the need grew the
program expanded now pivot has 26 little
houses on over 12 acres of land built
with the help of private donations along
with state and federal grants residents
initially pay one hundred dollars a
month for a home of around 300 square
feet with a living space a kitchen and a
bathroom tenants can't have overnight
guests and have to keep the place clean
pivot CEO Jennifer Goodrich says the
goal is to get residents ready for the
real world in two years by helping them
find jobs get counseling and plan for a
better tomorrow it's essential because
if you don't know where you're going you
can't get there right we give them voice
and choice like what do you want it to
be but a lot of times they're not aware
of what are the steps to get down that
path government data shows nearly 4 000
people sleep on Oklahoma streets every
day almost 300 of them are between 18
and 24 years old
harder Batcher was 16 when he went into
foster care then bounced around shelters
when he turned 18. he was the first
person to enter pivot's Little House
program it was like the whole world was
on my shoulders and finally somebody
just kind of lifted it just a little bit
and I could breathe easier and I
wouldn't have to worry about where I was
going to sleep that night or if someone
was going to steal my stuff and I could
just go to sleep for peacefully for the
first time in what felt like years Barry
is learning the basics and building a
big future from her little home I think
this is an opportunity that I don't
think anybody should pass up for CBS
mornings I'm Omar villafranca in
Oklahoma City
it's a great idea yeah it seems like a
great idea yeah yeah right for some
people when you turn 18 you're excited
I'm an adult I can't see the world for
other people it's probably the worst
time of their lives oh no yeah yeah when
you age out of the system there's
nowhere to go crash back to right about
this give them a place to be just to
feel safe we put we take it for granted
that you go home just that you have a
place to go so they have some place to
go and feel safe is huge we'll see all
right